voilà ça c'est très bien ça aussi c'est
un bel outil bien les enfants est ce
qu'il y à d'autres outils
oui oui là on tente m'a apporté un beau
tournevis
non c'est pas un tournevis ça ça fait
rien or frédéric son arrosoir et très
beau je vais le mettre là voilà un mois
au lit vielles parfum c'est bien ça bon
bah écoutez là et je crois que ça
suffira à bonjour vous êtes là quand je
suis très content de vous voir
oui nous avons tous ensemble regrouper
des outils pour que françois choisissent
ce qu'ils préfèrent
oui vous savez pourquoi n'est ce pas et
bien parce que ça oui
qu'est-ce que ça à julie ah là là
bonjour c'est toute une installation
ouais que fais-tu tous ces outils tu les
bonds us pour un jeu non non c'est pour
françois à pouilly la commander tous ces
outils
mais non je vous lui en offrir quelques
uns parce que je trouve qu'il travaille
beaucoup avec sa tête mais pas beaucoup
avec ses mains tu as raison
les métiers manuels sont des métiers
formidable mais pourquoi lui offrir tue
tous ces outils maintenant julie tu n'as
pas vu le calendrier
que se passe-t-il au caire a fait
attention
c'est bientôt le 4 octobre enfin amener
oui j'ai oublié c'est la salle françois
tu vois que parfois je sers à quelque
chose tu es toujours très utile merci
merci
mais tu sais ça mérite aussi une une
récompense qui se mange gourbault qu'est
ce que tu veux
j'aimerais bien avoir tu sais les
dragées au poivre que tu range sur
l'étagère des farces et attrapes
je ne sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs bon
ben je vais te chercher
merci pendant ce temps là j'avais
commencé à classer les outils vous
falloir il ya des outils de menuisier
deux maçons de jardiniers et de
mécaniciens de voiture c'est très facile
je crois prenons par exemple le premier
ça je crois que c'est attendez je me
souviens plus du nom à voilà oui c'est
un grattoir pour les fleurs oui c'est
pour gratter les petites fleurs quand
elles ont des démangeaisons bien voilà
ta dragées au poivre petit mire grand
merci julie merci elle est délicieuse tu
sais aller juste poivre et assouan est
ce que tu veux que je t'aide à classer
les outils pendant que c'est pas la
peine je me débrouille très bien tout
seul regard dont j'ai déjà trouvé le
grattoir pour les fleurs quand elles ont
des démangeaisons
oui c'est justement ce qui m'inquiète
quoi pourquoi parce que ça n'est pas un
grattoir c'est un rabot et ce n'est pas
le jardinier qui s'en sert mais le
menuisier
tu es sûr bah oui vraiment sur moi bien
sûr
si tu ne me crois pas nous allons
demander aux enfants tient bon si tu
veux tu sais c'est parce que j'ai pas
confiance en toi mais ils ont toujours
des idées très bonne les enfants là bas
vous êtes tous là oui on va on va les
classes et ensemble donc vous savez les
variétés casimir tient du mas lui donner
le nom des outils et vous allez essayer
de lui dire auquel de ses quatre métiers
ces outils sont destinés alors
menuisiers des nations mais calyssia
mécanicien d'auto à rien et jardiniers
bien on commence par quels outils elle
écoute on va voir si tu t'es pas trompé
1 quel est le nom de celui là
votre aide qu'elle mérite son joli
ensuite voilà qu'elle ya cette étiquette
bien ça ça quand c'est drôle on dirait
un genou et bh et vous aussi
comment ça s'appelle personnes on sait
je vois ok oui c'est une clé mais une
clé à bougie
tu sais une clé à bougie voiture mais
c'est une partie du moteur
alors s'ils sont là c'est pour qui si
c'est pour un moteur à temps mécanicien
ses voiles à la bombe déjà deux c'est
déjà pas mal
ça c'est très bien ça s'appelle la bafa
et xavier trouvait alors
et de trois la pioche ses plus gros moi
j'appellerai ça une fourchette
non
bon c'est pas une fourchette ses pains
bio est une binette telle mission quel
métier très bien ils ont ça plus que moi
s'est interrogé lundi sur 10 mois voilà
vous avez tous trouvé qu est ce qu on
fait avec
ah oui oui moi un jour j'ai coupé les
cheveux de monsieur duchesneau a pas
vexer sa quasi vie voilà fédérer à
molette et qu'elle est liée mécanicien
cette chose là j'aimerais bien savoir le
maçon du croit frédéric lemonnier
oui on peut pas ce qu'on fait aussi mal
allées du bois
ouais ensuite ça c'est impressionnant
bravo dominique c'est à démontrer que
vous êtes car les mécaniques ont dû
montant l'épreuve
oui c'est pas pour les pneus l'a fait
monter les roues mécanicien
tout le monde le savait mémoire et la
grande échelle
comment ça s'appelle personnes non c'est
toi le 6 juillet moi moi si j non je
vous demanderai pas vous sauriez pas
l'affichage je sais c'est y loge ça
s'appelle une eau rouge et c'est pour
faire du ciment ou du plâtre alors quel
métier masse voilà voilà ça y est je
crois que tout est bien classé il était
temps regarde
bonjour tout le monde bonjour aux quels
beaux outils que voulez vous faire avec
tout ça à nous les avons classés pour
que tu nous dises perret le métier que
tu préfères comment veux tu que je te
réponde casimir il s'agit de quatre
métiers passionnants mais ce sont des
métiers difficiles qu'il faudra prendre
pendant longtemps si un jour on veut les
exercer correctement et pourtant tu vois
casimir j'aimerais beaucoup avoir tous
ces outils pour m'exercer à chacun de
ses métiers
d'ailleurs moi tu sais tout me passionne
ce qu'on peut apprendre avec son cerveau
est fabriqué avec ses mains et alors tu
veux aussi à quatre ans avant l'âge
aimerait beaucoup alors chanté nous ah
oui volontiers
[Musique]
très sale c'est ce que je voudrais
le
ignorez montpetit outre m
j'aimerais
elle connaît
m les fournit les souris ont des vies
extraordinaires jeu
on explique ses mystères je voudrais
être très savants connaître le secret
des choses
y at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants roses calquer at-il deviner ce
qu'on trouve au delà des êtres cannes il
voit ton parfois des lions d
s'ils gagnent les moyens les corbeaux et
il est donc tout à fait
les canes
là haut d'un cousin les dauphins l'est
parce qu'ils sont de vrais mammifères
son
des poissons dans la mer je voudrais
être très sale en connaître le secret
des chômeuses et il y at-il vraiment
quelque part des éléphants risquent un
acte il deviner ce qu'on trouve au delà
des épaules il voit tant par pas des
lions des hommes
segal
[Musique]
100 c'est ce que je voudrais
fini vraiment
très
g
et
sexy
ah ah ah ah
ah ah
[Musique]